salut c'est une seconde aujourd'hui on
va parler du samsung galaxy note 9
d'arriver d'ici quelques jours qui va
être présentée le 9 août prochain
new york on connaît quasiment toutes les
infos la fiche technique on connaît les
nouvelles fonctionnalités
c'est super intéressant et je pense que
ce galaxy note 9 devrait être plutôt
cool donc on va en parler maintenant
à chaque fois que samsung sort un
flagship c'est vrai que sa folle d'un
coup tout le monde c'est normal parce
que samsung innove énormément ailleurs
il faut savoir que c'est le numéro un
mondial au niveau des smartphones donc
samsung c'est quand même une énorme à
eelv était toujours un peu pour la
première place entre samsung nos côtés
et apple de l'autre là on attend avec
impatience l arrivée du note 9 c'est
vrai que on s'attend pas à voir un truc
hyper révolutionnaire il faudra attendre
début 2019 pour avoir un nouveau
flagship qui devrait vraiment un petit
peu changé
changer un peu la donne avec le galaxy s
10 et que latence surtout le galaxy x
qu'ils vont arriver aussi l'année
prochaine vont tous en avoir parlé on a
déjà beaucoup parlé de samsung galaxy x
callac 6x galaxie x je vous invite à
rester connectés à vous abonner
samsung n'est pas danser une info il ya
quelques jours annonçant un petit peu la
couleur on en sait davantage de façon
officielle cette fois ci sur le samsung
galaxy note mais on sait qu'il aura une
meilleure autonomie on sait qu'il aura
plus de performances et on sait aussi
qu'il aura plus de stockage
en plus de ça dans communiqué de presse
une petite info très intéressante que
nokia samsung ou sony device eeyou need
to manage your workplace in between ce
qui tend à prouver que samsung s'adresse
effectivement a coûté un peu
professionnel work au gamer avec play in
every thing et des twins à ces messieurs
dames tout le monde
à orcières donc une site trip on va pas
à parler de la même manière à un
professionnel qu'on va parler à un gamer
qu'on va parler au grand public ça veut
donc dire un produit vaut réellement
complet et surtout extrêmement
performant parce que si on veut
s'adapter directement gamer il faut de
la puissance
il faut de la ram il faut un processeur
puissant et il faut du stockage et c'est
effectivement ce que d'annoncer samsung
dans son nouveau communiqué donc là on
est plutôt raccord côté professionnel on
garde toujours le s pen qui va être revu
et corrigé messager vous le détailler
dans quelques instants
et puis et vous écris mes between
monsieur et madame tout le monde donc
les photos les applications tout ce que
vous voulez voir ça il peut le faire qui
peut le plus peut le moins
donc ça pourrait d'ailleurs le slogan de
ce samsung galaxy note d'ailleurs au
sujet des baigneurs il ya une foule qui
est super intéressante c'est que
fortnight devrait sortir en exclusivité
pendant 30 jours
uniquement sur le galaxy note 9
pour le temps fort night est disponible
uniquement sur un os ça fait longtemps
qu'on attend une version android est là
justement elle devrait arriver sur ce
galaxy note 9 est à noter que c'est
aussi un coup de maître de la part de
samsung
cela permet d'illustrer que 99 et un
smartphone qui est également destinée
aux gamers et avec une licence en exclu
pendant 30 jours comme fortnight ça
déchire puisque ça ne nous annonce une
grosse autonomie il va forcément y avoir
une batterie un peu puissante autres et
c'est un peu le souci avec le note 7
alors on oublie on enterre tout ce
problème parce que ça me saoulait su
démontrer qu'ils étaient extrêmement
fort et picard problèmes techniques ça
peut arriver là avec le note 9 on
devrait avoir une batterie de 4000
milliampères heures donc grosse
autonomie
d'ailleurs on a vu un document sur
l'agencé brésilienne de
télécommunications qui s'appelle anatel
qui fait effectivement référence à un
smartphone avec une batterie de 4000
milles et operation of young pour tout
porte à penser que c'est effectivement
pour les galaxy note 9 mois est
maintenant qu en est il du côté du
design
le design devrait franchement similaire
au nôtre 8 il n'y a pas eu grande
évolution entre la suite et le x900 pas
non plus de grandes évolutions entre le
no 8 et le note 9
néanmoins on doit avoir un smartphone
qui innove qui a plein de points
vraiment d'amélioration par rapport à la
version précédente mais il devrait
bénéficier et des nouveautés des
innovations présentes dans les galaxies
s9 plus à noter qu'il ya des fabricants
de coqs qui ont fait fuiter des images
ont fait fuiter directement ou
indirectement toute critique on a
retrouvé les images sur internet qui
vous présente qui vous montre le galaxy
note peuple tel qu'il va être on voit à
l'arrière un double module caméra comme
on retrouve déjà sur le galaxy note 8
un flash led juste à la gauche justin à
gauche ou à la droite cela dépend si
c'est vous qui le regardaient ou si vous
placez à la position du smartphone en
dessous un capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour le déverrouiller
renforcement de reconnaissance faciale
avec le fun loeb mais pas d'équivalent à
priori dufeil saïdi là-dessus pense que
samsung est un petit peu la nouveauté
début
2019 pour sortir un ace 10 avec a priori
un lecteur d'empreinte digitale intégrée
directement à l'écran ce qui leur
permettrait de se différencier dans
quelque chose de très pratique de faire
un petit peu différemment de ce que
propose apple avec son galaxy 10 et
schumi avec son 1008 explorer edition il
serait disponible en quatre couleurs
bleu marron violet et le noir le design
reste quand même si l'air asu d'une
autre suite parlé de grandes innovations
un produit qui devrait par contre avoir
un écran légèrement plus grand ou
d'avoir un écran de 6 à 3 pouces on
devrait avoir un écran de 18,4 pouces ça
n'a pas changé la face du monde une
résolution 2960 points 1440 pixels un
ratio 18 points 5/9 est bien évidemment
toujours un écran super amoled made in
samsung display qu'en est il maintenant
des caméras royaux change un petit peu
de blanc l'un ça fait un peu bikers
comme ça se présente un joli petit duc à
petit oui ça change un peu du front
classique en rajoute un petit peu de
choses sur la chaîne est ce très joli
rouge que vous pouvez voir ici n'est pas
sympathique bon on reprend qu'en est il
justement du module photo parce que sur
le nom de suite aurait débuté jacques
avait un double module photo à l'arrière
là le note 9 va continuer les donc avoir
deux caméras de 12 mégapixels la
première aura une lentille d ouverture
variable comme sur les smartphones
peuvent plus c'est à dire une ouverture
soit en f 2.4 soit en f1 points 5 donc
extrêmement puissant en faible
luminosité et une deuxième optique à
capteur 12 mégapixels qui vous permettra
d'avoir une fois 2 et surtout d'abord un
magnifique effet bloqué vous pourrez
faire du slow motion en 960 images par
seconde est ce qu'on aura un super slow
mots en 720p ou alors 80 pc en 1080p
c'est un peu le point d'interrogation
faudra vraiment sur ce produit on passe
directement en 1080p va forcément y
avoir de la puissance avec un exynos
9810 en europe et 1,5 dragon 845 qui
devrait a priori être couplé à six liga
drame au minimum et même une version un
peu plus sûr booster avec 8 gigas de ram
donc une bécane qui va vraiment avoir de
la puissance pour le jeu et pour faire
du super slow mots en 1080p dans aucun
problème on trouvera aussi très
logiquement les arm hodges source note 9
[Musique]
et elle avant de retrouver un minimum
caméra de 8 mégapixels peut-être
peut-être retrouvera-t-on un double
module photo comme son profond regret
que s'ils habitent vous avez la présence
à l'avant ici de la double caméra
frontale ça serait logique en tout cas
sur un produit très haut de gamme
c'est d'ailleurs le produit le plus haut
de gamme de chez samsung doit retrouver
un double module photo l'avant ça
permettrait d'avoir un produit
extrêmement complet double module photo
arriérés avec lentille ouverture
variable double module photo avant ça
serait juste top au niveau de la photo
bon allez l'ol dans tout ça qu'est-ce
qu'on va retrouver
alors on imagine pouvoir retrouver assez
simplement un androïde 8.0 8.1 oreo mais
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas un androïde p
ça pourrait avoir un sens de retrouver
un androïde paix au lancement de galaxy
note 9 ça on saura d'ici quelques jours
toute façon je vous le dis à rester
connectés parce que dès que produit va
sortir et va être annoncée
officiellement présenté je serai là
juste après donc faire un petit peu le
débrief lire un petit entre les lignes
voir à qui il s'adresse même si on
connaît effectivement le quart no 6 de
ce produit mais on en parlera davantage
quand on aura toutes les infos 500 nous
a vraiment mis en avant la capacité de
stockage dont on imagine pour apparue
toute version 32 gigas pas de version 64
on aura un minima une version 128 go de
stockage
on devrait donc avoir une version 128 go
de stockage 256 et 512 2 usb type c'est
la possibilité d'avoir soit une simple
carte sim soit une double carte sim la
prise jack qu'on voit sur les photos des
coques bien évidemment la mémoire
extensible avec une carte micro sd bon
si vous achetez la config en 512 giga je
suis pas sûr vous en avant extension en
tout cas pourquoi pas une certification
il payer 68 et un smartphone de base
avec la version 128 giga qui devrait à
1059 euros en france est disponible à
partir du 24 août
dossier par une version surboosté en 512
giga à 1259 euros autre nouveauté et pas
des moindres le decs devrait exister et
disparaître à la fois c'est à dire qu'on
peut l'utiliser en mode ordinateur de
bureau avec le système d'aix n'aurait
plus de petits boîtiers physique vous
auriez dit un adaptateur usb type c'est
vers hdmi pour relier directement un
éditeur pour utiliser le galaxy note 9
comme un trackpad pour l'utiliser comme
une souris avoir impliqué aviez virtuel
directement dessus et autres galaxy note
9 lui viendrait tout seul et sans devoir
malade et en accessoires d'aix
et tout le temps un véritable ordinateur
ce qui fait vous pourriez vous connecter
partout tout le temps juste à gré
smartphones quel adaptateur ce permettra
donc à samsung d'être plus performant de
pallier au problème d'avoir un petit
d'ex emmener partout avec soi et ça
c'est plutôt intéressante pour un usage
professionnel peut imaginer aussi pour
un usage familial
pourquoi pas pouvoir prendre son
ordinateur en permanence le brochet bon
je suis pas ce soir à terme réellement
pratique de pas voir clavier ou pas
voire mieux comparé à bosser dessus mais
pourquoi pas dernière nouveauté est
franchement pas des moindres c'est le s
pen ne s'est pas encore parler de
l'espagne l'espagne va continuer à
évoluer
on pourra voir plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités alors qu'on ne connaît
pas tout aujourd'hui en tout cas ce qui
pourrait être intéressant c'est que le s
pen devrait se connecter en bluetooth
directement à votre galaxy note l'ofs
et ce qui lui permettrait surtout de
l'utiliser un peu comme une télécommande
vous pourriez déclencher des photos à
distance
vous pourriez augmenter ou baisser le
son de votre smartphone on imagine si
vous le branchez un ancien de connecter
ça me permet de piloter un petit peu de
distance ne pas être obligé de venir
forcément monter directement le
somptueux vous pourriez déverrouiller
directement avec entre l'espagne et du
riz pas mal de fonctionnalités et des
petits raccourcis qui serait vraiment
très pratique et qu'il pourrait vraiment
vous améliorer la vie imagine pardon
pour prendre une photo vous le posez
vous mettez en phase avec des amis au
lieu d'avoir un compte à rebours de 10
secondes - le général on va s'endetter
on prend classe poteau pour sochaux fait
trois quatre photos vous avez forcément
une photo réussie là dedans et ça c'est
un point vraiment positif
à la question est-ce que ce galaxy note
9 devrait être révolutionnaire la
réponse est très franchement non pas du
tout ce galaxy note nappe devrait être
une évolution à mi chemin entre galaxy
note 8 galaxy s le fsf plus les grandes
évolutions on les attend pour 2019 si
vous avez besoin d'un smartphone avec un
stylet tout de suite maintenant vous
pouvez pas attendre le galaxy note 9
pourrait être fait pour vous bien
évidemment on va attendre d'en savoir
plus on va attendre que samsung le
présente pour avoir toutes les infos
officielles et voir un petit peu s'il ya
des nouveautés qui peuvent vraiment nous
surprendre surtout des cas visage des
utilisations qu'on pourrait encore
ignorer à ce jour bon je pense pas en
règle générale quelques jours du
lancement
on sait quasiment tout on a vraiment des
gros si le porteur robots mais une fois
de plus resté connecté pas trop en
parler
d'ailleurs en apprenant aux dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez qu est ce que
vous voudriez avoir comme fonctionnalité
sur ce galaxy note 9
vous ne marquez tout ça en commenter a
bien évidemment on en reparle d'ici
quelques jours
parce qu'il est présenté le 9 août à new
york malheureusement je ne serai pas de
la fête
il est par contre je vais derrière mon
écran je vais tout noté de tout voir
tout débris fait durant en parler
ensemble
merci à vous d'être présent toujours
plus nombreux toujours plus nombreux
j'habite comme d'hab à vous abonner à
rester connectés parce qu'on parlait
toujours plus de paix qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses qui arrivent dans les temps à
venir des nouveautés dévoilées ce normal
de trudeau restez connectés je vous dis
à très bientôt
on fait des gros bisous laisse moi
toutes vos questions suggestions tout ce
que vous voulez en commentaire en bas
soyez sage et très bientôt et je vous
embrasse ciao
[Musique]